losing your head can be a little
frustrating in previous videos we've
already seen creators rip a gods skull
from his body and Leon's visit to dr.
Salazar in Resident Evil 4 didn't go as
planned
the vast system in fallout 3 let us
target specific limbs now we crave the
ability to decapitate our opponents at
every opportunity with that in mind here
are 6 video game decapitations
definitely not for the squeamish back in
2004 a little non classic game was
released on the ps2 and PC
it was the Punisher you play as Frank
Castle and murder your way through Stark
Industries and a host of other locations
the game offered a mechanic like no
other when Frank needs information he
can interrogate his victims using the
environment around him when he bricks
his targets will and they give him the
information he needs he can let them go
or he can kill them all
our favorite has to be the COG takedown
which removes the enemies head from
their lifeless body
keep him with the comic-book heroes our
next entry is the terrible game that was
x-men origins Wolverine it had the
occasional shining light throughout
including this very unique way of taking
down a helicopter pilot
he even finishes off with a superhero
landing
well played Logan well played if one
thing the Game of Thrones TV series has
taught us is that decapitation is a
regular occurrence in Westeros the video
game tie-in from telltale continued this
trend and please switch off now if you
haven't played Game of Thrones as this
is definitely a spoiler there must have
gone by now yeah in the final act of the
game your beautiful handmade and mirror
must decide if her life or her morals
are more important to her if she chooses
her principles she is met by this demise
worse still if she decides she wants to
live she must frame a young Cole boy who
has been helping her through the entire
game keeping your head in Game of
Thrones is a difficult affair at this
point we plan to introduce a Mortal
Kombat execution but there were so many
we couldn't decide on one so therefore
we're going to make a video just
dedicated to Mortal Kombat and sub-zero
and his friends so please stay tuned for
that one instead I've decided to bring
back until dawn and Chris is subtle
decapitation when can we looking around
his campsite
please drop back to earth his face still
twitches stuff of nightmares for our
penultimate head removal we are
switching to the Resident Evil franchise
and the great feeling of removing a
zombie's head whether it's kicking the
head off the rotten shoulders of a
crawling zombie are waiting in earnest
to shotgun the head off an over friendly
zombie that requires a hook 20 years
later and it's still as satisfying as it
was in 1996 we've reached the top of the
list and it's from while honor choosing
between Vikings nights are our favorite
the samurai your job is to defeat them
and murder the opposition if done
correctly you can utilize a decapitation
maneuver to strike fear into your
opponent's there are some mind-blowing
finishes on offer but you know me
samurai for the wind so that was our
list of 6 video game decapitations
definitely not for the squeamish do you
agree with the list what have we missed
let us know if you look please oh and
one other thing please subscribe to our
tiny channel and help us grow we really
want to reach more people and we need
your help I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade I'll see you next time